[Music]
let's take a hard left turn into
seriousness
shall we okay now during a speech
on racial equity this week president
biden ordered the federal agency that
oversees housing
to correct the quote historical racism
in federal housing policies but you may
be asking yourself
where did those policies come from in
the first place how did we get here
we'd like to break that down for you now
in a segment called how did we get here
lately there's been a lot of talk about
systemic racism
everyone claims they want to fix it but
we can't even agree on what it
is we just know it's bad like poverty or
pollution
or the way white people dance but
systemic racism isn't just an idea it's
a real thing
there's a place where you can go and see
real live systemic racism right in front
of you
it's called the hood i'm sure you've
heard about it your favorite rapper grew
up there
you've probably seen movies about it in
a movie you can tell you're in the hood
because there's always rap music playing
in the background when the brave white
savior goes there to drag jamal away
from the gang
so he can play in the big chess
tournament but have you ever wondered
how the hood got that way systemic
racism that's how
in the 1930s america was in the thick of
the great depression
the banks had failed and everyone had
lost their homes and unemployment was at
the highest it would ever be
until this idiot came along so fdr had
an idea called the new deal
the new deal gave jobs to nearly every
american set the minimum wage and
created a retirement plan called social
security and it worked
for the first time in american history
you could have a regular job
and make a decent living you wouldn't
necessarily be rich but
you wouldn't be poor either they called
it the middle class
to get that kind of job security today
you would need three jobs and an only
fan's account
now if you're wondering if this new deal
made things better for black people
the answer is see part of the new deal
was
the homeowners loan corporation they
were an organization that guaranteed
home loans for everyone
but just like an episode of friends they
didn't include black people
how could they separate the white
applicants from the black applicants
they didn't have to segregation did that
for them because of segregation laws
black people could only live in certain
areas
so the united states government drew up
color-coded maps for nearly every city
in america and told the banks
we'll guarantee loans for everyone who
lives anywhere except in the red
areas those just so happen to be the
areas where black people lived
like how the only thing behind glass at
walgreens just so happens to be miss
jessie's
they created a system based on racism to
make sure black people couldn't be a
part of this middle class
they came up with a name for it too they
called it redlining
we called it the hood but that's way in
the past right like downton abbey phones
and these pants
what does that have to do with now well
how many of you watching right now
live in or know someone who lives in a
home that their parents or grandparents
owned
that's called generational wealth and
home ownership is the number one driver
of wealth in america
number two of course is how many beanie
babies you have
you can use a home to pay for college or
start a business or you know
not be homeless but if you look at
almost any major american city
most of the formerly redlined areas are
still majority black and low-income
that's because banks didn't stop doing
this until hold on let me look it up
let's see when did banks stop they never
stopped homes in majority black
neighborhoods are valued
at 25 percent lower than homes in white
areas
even when the crime rate and the
neighborhood amenities are exactly the
same and
because school funding is based on home
values
the average non-white school district
receives two thousand two hundred and
twenty six dollars
less per student than a white school
district which is why the gym in a
public school
in a black neighborhood looks like this
and the gym
at a white school looks like this
there's even studies that show schools
in black neighborhoods have smaller
libraries meanwhile at the white school
they're checking out encyclopedia brown
from here
and because wealth and education are the
number one factors for crime
police are more likely to patrol these
neighborhoods which is why even though
there is no difference in the rate of
drug use between white and black people
let me say that again there is no
difference in the rate of drug use
between white and black people
black people are three and a half times
more likely to be arrested for drugs
it's like a reverse hunger games where
the odds are never
in your favor most drug arrests occur in
redlined areas and
studies show courts hand out 20 percent
longer sentences to black people who
commit the same crimes as white people
wait maybe that's why white people dance
like that it's the dance of a person
with
no consequences so maybe all of this is
why the average white family has
10 times the wealth of a black family
not because black people like
jordans and shiny rims but because there
is a system
designed specifically to make it true
homeownership in america is more rigged
than a basketball hoop at coney island
and
maybe that's why black people are always
rapping and bragging about where we come
from
we're not celebrating the hood we're
letting you know that we survived a
system that took our free labor
and our tax dollars and gave it to
everyone but us
we're telling the world in no uncertain
terms that y'all can't kill us and we
won't die
so if you want to know what systemic
racism looks like
just go to the hood and tell jamal good
luck at the chess tournament
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you